okay so now I have played with kids that
haven't had any rough-and-tumble play
and it's really hard to play with them
partly because they're there they're
easily frightened you know they'd like
to play I know how to play with kids
they'd like to play they're pretty kept
up on it you know and they really
excited especially about physical play
but they're awkward you know so you play
with them they stick their thumb in your
eye or you know or they cry really
easily when nothing really happens and
like they just don't have it together
a kid that has done a lot of physical
interaction physical play that kid it's
a different sort of kid because the
first thing the kid knows it's not a
rule the first thing the kid knows is
how forceful can he be with you so that
it's exciting and interesting and fun
but it's not too much and that's really
an interesting questioning because
actually to really play a good game like
a physical contact game like wrestling
with a kid is that you want to let that
kid come right up to the edge of hurting
you and the closer the kid gets to the
edge the more fun it is for both because
the kid will give you a whack and it go
you know and and that's it's good you
know and then maybe he'll give you a
harder whack to see if he can get away
with it and kids will often they'll come
up to you whack you and then run away
and then they'll look and if you're
laughing then they'll come back and try
a harder one and then you know they're
doing it incrementally because it's
exploratory behavior and part of the
exploration is okay what our bodies like
and the answer that is well what can you
get away with doing to them but it's a
more sophisticated answer to which is
what can you get away with doing to them
in a way that allows you to continue to
explore without fear or punishment and
without blowing the whole game to bits
okay so how do you figure that out you
do not talk about it because you can't
you have to act it out it's like so so
the kids hitting you and wrestling and
pulling your hair and doing all these
things and you're modifying its behavior
very very carefully and and and in my
miniscule detail and then you get a kid
who can like wrestle like mad and
they're fun to play with they bounce
around like a dog that won't bite you
you know a good well-trained dog
you can really play with and you can
play with them rough and it's a blast
the dog has a good time the person has a
good time it's like excellent that's a
socialized dog so the other thing that
kids learned learns which is quite cool
is what hurts them and what doesn't and
how afraid can they be and still have
fun so you know when you're wrestling
with the kid you put them you know you
put them face down you put your elbow on
them you bend them around you throw them
in the air and catch them you know
you've grabbed it by the leg and maybe
you pull them over and you know and what
you're showing the kid is here's a bunch
of things that your body can do and it's
okay that they're they're being done
that it isn't gonna hurt you and you're
not talking about you're showing them
and so the kid gets kind of confident
about what he or she can withstand
physically and the difference between
pain and not pain and the difference
between fear and not fear and win
something's threatening and when it's
not it's very sophisticated it's very
sophisticated behavior and that's partly
why kids love to play now one of the
things that's happened which is you know
an indication of a deep sickness in our
society is that I used to work in a day
care center and when I was about your
age because I really like kids and they
like to play with me because I know how
to play with them and so one of the
things I would do with the little kids
was I would draw them horrible monsters
right like big teeth things on I just
sketched them out they weren't any works
of art you know but those damn kids they
would line up to get a picture of a
monster draw me a picture of the monster
draw me a picture of a monster it's like
they love those little pictures of
monsters so that was pretty funny and
another thing I would do is play with
them you know I'd take them out in the
yard and grab an arm and a leg and spin
them around and bend them over and you
know twist them around let them crawl on
me and there was there was always one
kid in the group who couldn't do that
doll he's like he hadn't been paid
attention to enough you know so he was I
think he was like a Taoist uncarved
block very vague and ill-defined and
clunky and so kid like that you know
you'd sit down it's so sad you sit down
and you're interacting with the kids and
that kid comes along sort of lumping
along you know like this
and they plop you plop on your lap and
they like they're about as sophisticated
as like a six month old you know and
they're quite annoying you know which is
a horrible thing because they're so
desperate for attention and it's too
late often by the time they're four it's
like good luck fixing that man it's not
gonna happen you know those kids are
just screwed because what happens to
them is they're so lumpy and ill-formed
and and uncomfortable in their body and
socially clueless and inattentive and
blind and ignored and resentful that no
other kids will play with them and it's
no wonder because their other kids are
way the hell up on the play development
trend and so they're bored stiff by them
it's like playing with a nine-month-old
which kids will do you know but that's
not pure play and so those kids just
drift off they get they stay on the
outside of the peer group and they never
get into it they never get into it so
very very ugly and so now in daycare
centers you can't touch the kids it's
like what the hell you know well why
well because he can't distinguish play
for molesting it's like who can't
distinguish that you know and what are
you gonna do you're not gonna you're
gonna deprive the kids of play because
of your stupid paranoia that's the whole
that's the whole process right brilliant
brilliant you know what you're doing is
you're teaching children that adults are
so dangerous that they can't be trusted
to be near you that's a lovely thing to
teach children especially because
they're going to be adults